searching for the Dead
in an undescript field away from any
town or city there looking for the
missing people who should have been
buried by their families two decades ago
over 1 600 people remain unaccounted for
kosovars say their bodies were
deliberately hidden by Yugoslav and Serb
forces seeking to conceal war crimes
Kosovo authorities and international
organizations have been working to find
them passes the way that people are
farmed they build houses they build
roads the more difficult it is also the
memory of the people fail as well as one
of the problems it's difficult to
remember what you saw 23 years ago so
you may remember the event but you may
not remember the actual location of the
of the event among the victims of the
conflict were 1024 children this
exhibition in Pristina tells their story
children's belongings donated by their
families a school bag a drawing painful
memories
109 children still remain missing even
though there was a green cooperation
between Kosovo and Serbia in the
Brussels dialogue to resolve the issue
of missing persons I really don't have
really high high hopes
it's obvious that some information about
the possible location of a massive or
individual Graves
are only in the private archives or in
that memories of of certain people
's father was a doctor he went missing a
month after she was born and never got
to see his daughter such a long wait
until now 24 years have been a very long
and anxious and terrible weight
every aspect of Our Lives has definitely
been imbued by the absence of my father
and my uncle
so I can just say that they're absent
absence was the most present thing in
our life her father has a hospital named
after him but what they really want is
closure back in the field the work
continues some Musgraves have been
discovered in neighboring Serbia the
team hopes to return there to continue
investigations they also hope that
evidence collected will lead to
prosecutions in The Hague the
painstaking work of trying to find the
missing persons continues experts here
use eyewitness accounts satellite
imagery reports from NATO and other
organizations so they can give the
families of the missing people some sort
of closure I said Kosovo